Hey everyone.  We are in chapter eight where we look at supply, demand and market equilibrium.
We have a couple questions here that address all those topics.
Let's go ahead and dive into it.
Our first question asks which of the following best defines the quote relevant market when analyzing the impact of a new ride sharing app.
So relevant market are going to be any market where this app would be operating.
So it wouldn't be somewhere where the app doesn't necessarily need to define itself.
So all US Transportation perhaps doesn't need to define itself as a new ride sharing app.
Now you could look at it as in let's roll out Uber or Lyft.
They do have an app that is for everywhere, but that app really is based on the location of where the consumer happens to be.
So in this particular case, what we really want to look at is something like that, which gives us C as our answer.
Local personal transportation.
So in this particular case we're looking at where is the consumer located?
Yeah, they're located everywhere.
But do I really need to look at all US Transportation?
I don't really need to include planes, I don't need to include trains, but I do need to include automobiles.
So that's why we're looking at local personal transportation as our particular answer.
Car manufacturers doesn't make sense.
That's its own market altogether.
All mobile apps will be too broad of a definition for relevant market.
So C is going to be our answer there.  Let me just mark it.  There we go.
Next question.
Given the following demand and supply equations, we have demand sqd equals 120 minus 4p.
Supply is qs equals 6pminus 60.
What is the equilibrium price?
To find equilibrium price, what we need to do is is set our quantity demand equal to our quantity supplied.
So let's do that.
120 minus 4p is equal to 6pminus 60.
I'm going to pull the 60 over to the left hand side to get 180.
I'm going to pull the minus 4p over to the right hand side to get 10p, which means that p is equal to $18.
And that is my answer there.
So that's my market equilibrium price.
Next question.
A drought reduces the supply of wheat and this shifts the supply curve to the left.  Wow.
Okay, so this one hadn't told me what it does with the supply curve, what happens to the market.
So let's go ahead and just draw in what this might look like.
So here's the original supply curve.
That's kind of a crooked demand curve.
My quantity, my price the original market equilibrium price, the original market equilibrium quantity.
But because the supply of wheat decreases, this is going to shift the supply curve for a lot of things that use wheat because it's a relevant resource.
So it's going to shift this to the left.
What we see here, assuming no other changes in demand, what we're going to get is a quantity that falls and a price that is going to rise.
So see here, price rises, quantity falls is going to be our answer.
All right, which of the following scenarios would most likely cause the demand curve for electric vehicles to shift to the right?
So we're looking for determinants of demand to include income taxes, price of future goods, complement substitutes, those kind of things that go into shifting demand.
And we're talking about increasing demand because it's shifting to the right.
So what we're looking for is an increase in demand for electric vehicles, their EVs.
What is going to cause that?
A decrease in the price of EV batteries?  Not necessarily.
That's more of a supply curve shifter.
And that will necessarily increase supply because it reduces the cost of production.
A government subsidy for EV buyers.
Yeah, that's our answer right there.
That will increase demand because that gives consumers more income, more implicit income, not more earned income, but more implicit income.
Because if I have, let's say I make $100,000 and the government gives me a $20,000 subsidy by EV, then I necessarily have $120,000 if that's the car that I want to purchase.
So that will increase my demand rise in the price of EVs will decrease the quantity demand, not change in demand.
And improvement in battery production technology.
Again, that's going to be a supply curve shifter, which will increase our supply there.
Given the following demand and supply equations that we have another one where we need to figure out a few things.
What is the shortage if the price is fixed at $20?
So all we need to do is take the price here, plug it into where we see the letter P in both of those equations.  So let's do that.
QD is equal to 150 minus 2 times 20.
So that's 150 minus 40, which is going to give me 110 Qs.
Excuse me, is 3 times 20 minus 30, and that's going to give me 60 minus 30, which is 30.
The difference between those two is the shortage, which is going to be 80.
Remember, shortages occur when quantity demand is greater than quantity supplied.
Graphically, what we would see is something that looks like this much better demand curve that time.
And we have A price of what it say, $20.
So our quantity demand is right there.
Our quantity supplied is right there.
We found that this was 30 for quantity supplied.
We found this was 110 for our quantity demand.
And so what we end up getting is that shortage of 80 units.
So C is going to be our answer there.
All right, next question.
Which of the following is a movement along the demand curve, not a shift in the demand curve?
Remember, there's only one thing that causes us to move along a demand curve.
And so what we're talking about here, let's draw it in.
I'm going to do a better job than that.
Let's draw it in.
That's better.
And price, demand curve, what we're talking about here.
Remember, the law of demand says there's an inverse relationship between the price of a good and the quantity demanded of that good.
All else equal.
And if my price falls from P1 to P2, my quantity demand will rise from Q1 to Q2.
So quantity demand rises when price falls.
That's the only thing that causes a movement along the demand curve.
We are literally moving along the demand curve.
We are not shifting the demand curve.
We're not doing this.
So put a big X there, moving along the demand curve.
So we are looking at a discount.
I don't really like the way this is phrased, but a discount in the goods on price.
The other items there increase in consumer income, that increases demand.
Drop in the price of a substitute good, that decreases demand as you shift towards the substitute good.
Change in consumer preference could either increase or decrease demand depending on which way that change flows.
So that's why D there is our answer.
It's the only thing that causes a movement along the demand curve, not a change in the demand curve.
And then here's our last question.
We finally have a graph that we're going to be dealing with.
Let's have.  I'm changing my colors.
That's why you can't see things here.
Refer to the graph on the right.  If the.
This is the market for oranges, okay, the market is in equilibrium at D0 and S0.
So D0, S0.
We're going to put a little black circle thing there to let me know that that's where my equilibrium is.
Suppose the land used to grow oranges has a major wildfire.
So if this is the market for oranges, the land for oranges has a major wildfire that's going to decrease the production of oranges.
So we know we can go ahead and shift that supply curve.
Back to the left, further, people begin to view vitamin C.
I don't know why they're just now viewing this, but they for some reason begin to view vitamin C as a more important nutrient.
So vitamin C is prevalent in oranges.
I have a glass of OJ in the morning and there we go.
That's going to increase the demand for oranges.
What's the likely effect on the price and quantity?
We see that supply decreases and demand is going to increase.
So if we start with the first, let's let supply decrease.
That's going to move this along this original demand curve, this point, but then demand increases, which puts us at this point.
So we can see now our new price is P3.
This is the only place that we see P3 and quantity stays the same at Q0.
This is what we call indeterminate.
Whenever we have a change in demand and supply, we know one of the items, price or quantity will change.
The issue is one of them remains indeterminate.
We actually have to know the magnitude, that is the distance between these two curves and these two curves.
We need to know the magnitude of those shifts in order to determine what happens to the indeterminate variable.
I could have increased demand a lot more and quantity would have risen.
I could have decreased or, excuse me, increase demand a little bit and my quantity would have fallen.
So it all depends on what happens, which is why I just left it as staying the same at Q0.
All right, that is it for chapter eight.
I hope you have enjoyed it.